[Musica]
Buonasera a tutti Grazie per questo
invito e grazie per essere qui
io dedicherò i miei minuti a raccontarvi
questa mia esperienza nel calcio
non a caso abbiamo voluto parlare di
Salento puro e meritocrazia perché
questa mia avventura nel mondo del
calcio è iniziato ormai otto anni fa
è nata per pura passione
e passione non solo per la scuola di
calcio
ma soprattutto una passione per il
territorio
per la nostra terra Io credo che una
delle più belle forme di identificazione
con il proprio territorio sia proprio il
sostegno il supporto alla squadra della
propria terra perché il supporto e
sostegno alla scuola della propria terra
crea un meccanismo virtuoso genera
un accentuare continuo della propria
identità Se ci pensate un modo più più
forte per connotare la propria
appartenenza la propria identità
rispetto all'appartenenza
e il supporto alla scuola del territorio
probabilmente non c'è
in questi anni io ho preso la squadra
insieme ai miei soci che era nelle
ultime posizioni della serie C
e oggi siamo qui a giocarci un
campionato di Serie A
in queste ultime due giornate cercando
di fare di tutto per conservare la serie
A che è un patrimonio per tutto il
territorio
ho scoperto un mondo che non conoscevo
ho scoperto che attraverso il calcio si
può sostenere la propria terra
in maniera inimmaginabile perché questo
perché pur essendo
Da sempre è stato un sostenitore ma ci
sono certe cose che dal di fuori non si
comprendano comprendano ho scoperto in
questi anni da presidente del Lecce che
la squadra di calcio del territorio il
Lecce ma credo che valga per altre
piazze dove c'è una forte
identificazione territoriale come in
questo caso il Lecce rappresenta
per tanti per tanti tifosi e questa è
una cosa che davvero non avevo capito un
supporto una compagnia un compagno di
viaggio in questi anni ho scoperto che
il Lecce
riempie la vita
di quei tifosi di quella gente che
innanzitutto che vivono lontano ho
trovato
in questi otto anni di trasferte in
tutta Italia una popolazione un mondo
che vive nel nord Italia nel centro
Italia nel nord Italia
Svizzera Germania Europa che
utilizzano la scuola di calcio
per sentirsi a casa
in tutte le trasferte ho incontrato
tante persone che pur di essere lì
presenti in quella trasferta a Milano a
Verona o a Genova hanno fatto
letteralmente pazzie per esserci perché
quella giornata per loro rappresenta un
modo per ritornare a casa pur andando a
Genova pur andando a Verona il solo
fatto di trovarsi in quella città con la
gente del proprio territorio col proprio
popolo poter parlare il dialetto poter
parlare della propria squadra ma questo
lo metto in fondo rappresenta
un modo per fare un viaggio Un tuffo
nella propria terra e a volte il
risultato del campo diventa quasi un
dettaglio
per chi ha la voglia di vivere quel
momento quel momento di identificazione
Ecco perché la squadra è un bagno
all'interno del proprio territorio ho
scoperto inoltre che Lecce
perciò lo tratto con così tanta serietà
e un compagno di viaggio per chi vive la
solitudine
per chi è malato voi Non immaginate
quanta gente con gravi problemi di
salute si aggrappa alla squadra della
propria terra
per avere un momento di conforto per
avere un momento di compagnia per avere
un momento di cui gioire di qualche cosa
ecco perché
la mia esperienza mi ha portato a capire
che
il calcio ma soprattutto una squadra
così rappresentativa del territorio è
qualcosa che va molto oltre ciò che
accade nei 90 minuti in ogni partita in
ogni domenica c'è una partita che si
gioca a tutti i giorni che si gioca
Tutti i giorni che si gioca a ogni ora
che quella di supporto di presenza della
squadra all'interno del territorio
il motivo per il quale gli ho chiesto
sin da subito i miei giocatori ai miei
allenatori che si sono succeduti nel
tempo di essere a disposizione del
territorio pensare che il calcio Inizia
e muoia in quei 90 minuti che sono
importanti sono fondamentali e riduttivo
la squadra di calcio del territorio deve
essere presente sul territorio ogni
giorno
a disposizione
della collettività a disposizione della
solidarietà a disposizione di chi è solo
a disposizione di chi non sta bene e
questo non deve essere necessariamente
visibile non deve essere necessariamente
esibito deve essere fatto e basta
deve essere
ogni giorno inculcato nella mentalità
dei calciatori
i nostri calciatori io non amo gli
atteggiamenti di vittiismo di vismo gli
atteggiamenti di
in cui il calciatore può pensare di
essere al di fuori di un territorio
bisogna viverlo ed ecco perché
il Salento diventa un qualcosa che si
nutre della scuola di calcio ma anche i
calciatori si nutrono di Salento noi
abbiamo una squadra la prima squadra
composta da molti giocatori stranieri E
abbiamo la spada primavera la squadra
giovanile che peraltro in questo momento
è prima in classifica e ha compiuto un
vero e proprio miracolo Sportivo Perché
se voi Guardate il campionato primavera
il campionato diciamo giovanile dei
giocatori under 19
scoprirete sempre di leggere la
classifica all'incontrario perché c'è
primo il Lecce e poi dopo c'è Juve Inter
e Milan in questo momento la Primavera
del Lecce rappresenta un modello a
livello nazionale bene gran parte dei
nostri giocatori sono giocatori
stranieri
perché il livello è talmente alto che i
bravi del territorio sicuramente vengono
presi ma ci sono anche tantissimi
giocatori stranieri a cui insegniamo sin
dal giorno 1
la cultura del posto in cui si trovano
non è un posto dove loro si trovano per
caso ne è un posto dove loro si trovano
di passaggio è un posto che devono
vivere comprendere e pur proveniendo da
mondi diversi da culture diverse devono
mettersi a disposizione del territorio
Come vi dicevo prima è la cosa più bella
è vedere giocatori stranieri che
imparano la salentinità con tutti i
pregi e tutti i difetti dell'essere
salentini e la vivono
della trasferiscono e lo facciamo sin
dal settore giovanile
in cui questi ragazzi crescono e sono a
disposizione del territorio
il nostro progetto Ecco perché parte dal
Salento pensate che siamo l'unica
società di calcio in Italia che produce
il proprio abbigliamento sportivo
non ci avvaliamo dei grandi Marchi
internazionali
che diciamo di cui usufruiscono tutte le
altre squadre di calcio nel proprio
abbigliamento sportivo il nostro
abbigliamento sportivo ha un marchio
nostro che richiama il territorio e
tutte le maglie che noi creiamo ogni
giorno auto produciamo da soli e devono
essere tutte maglie che richiamano il
territorio
ogni anno il nostro marketing produce
delle maglie che devono avere dei
richiami
al territorio dal primo anno in cui è
partita questa iniziativa in cui una
maglia rappresentava il solito slogan il
sole un'altra il mare e l'alto il vento
poi siamo andati addirittura con una
maglia un anno in tutti gli stati
d'Italia in cui in piccolo sembrava una
specie di ombra grigia su uno sfondo
bianco C'erano scritti tutti i nomi dei
comuni
che fanno parte della provincia di Lecce
tutti quanti ripetuti molte volte perché
dovevamo portare in giro per l'Italia
tutti i nomi della provincia di Lecce
poi abbiamo esibito sulla nostra maglia
quest'anno in Serie A C'è una nostra
maglia che presenta Uno Skyline
bellissimo della città di Lecce verrà
che era un modo per portare la città in
giro per tutta Italia Ecco perché si
parla di Salento messo a disposizione
della squadra e la squadra messa a
disposizione del Salento
per far questo però è arriva un altro
punto
del mio intervento
ci vuole un'organizzazione che sia
meritocratica
a volte si trascura il fatto che il
calcio
a grandi livelli soprattutto a grandi
livelli insegna meritocrazia
il calcio da opportunità a calciatori
che provengono dalle parti più sperdute
del mondo
Dalle condizioni più disagiate del mondo
e meriti sconosciuti che però hanno la
voglia di arrivare hanno la voglia di
essere di diventare dei professionisti
di imporsi
il calcio
pur avendo altri criticità altri difetti
che stanno per fortuna emergendo
in questi giorni
rispetto a come vengono tenuti i bilanci
a Come vengono
rispettate le regole sul fair play
finanziario lì sì che ci sono delle
criticità però c'è una grande
Come posso dire
c'è una grande propensione alla
meritocrazia è uno dei settori più
meritocratici pensate che uno dei motivi
per i quali i settori giovanili
a volte non crescono e rimangono un
costo per la società un costo inutile e
che nei settori giovanili entra il
figlio di l'amico di il figlio di
quell'altro però sono settori giovanili
che non producono niente e quelle
società sono destinate visto che il
settore giovanile e il motore e il
serbatoio per il futuro a non avere
futuro
Allora le grandi società quelle che sono
organizzate in maniera davvero
meritocratica non conoscono cognomi non
conoscono nazionalità non conoscono
Stato Sociale non conoscono
rilevanza di questo di quel personaggio
all'interno di determinati sistemi di
conoscenze conta solo la meritocrazia si
cerca di setacciare tutto il territorio
non solo quello Nazionale ma anche
quello internazionale e prendere i
migliori dove i migliori non sono
necessariamente o soltanto quelli che
sanno giocare bene a calcio ma sono
quelli che sono professionisti atleti
qui nella testa perché la grande
differenza Io ho visto alternarsi in
questi anni Tanti giovani di grande
qualità ma alla fine
Basta anche un po' di qualità in meno ma
essere grandi grandi professionisti sono
quelli che fanno la differenza sono
quelli che si fanno notare e sono quelli
che arriverebbero comunque per cui se
non ci arriva prima il Lecce e State
tranquilli che ci arriva un'altra
squadra
quindi nel calcio bisogna essere veloci
a scegliere più bravi perché per
arrivare a grandi livelli bisogna essere
meritocratici
per settore giovanile si arriva in prima
squadra per pura meritocrazia
dove Ripeto la meritocrazia e figlia di
un percorso difficilissimo
che parte dalle categorie minori e
arriva fino alla prima squadra in questo
momento
il calcio italiano nella scelta degli
Atleti e meritocratico
nella gestione delle regole non lo è
ancora nella gestione del rapporto tra
le società di calcio non lo è ancora le
società che si auto organizzano per
essere il più possibile meritocratiche
all'interno al proprio interno però poi
quando si affrontano tra di loro ancora
si affrontano in un sistema in cui non
c'è una piena meritocrazia pensate che
in Italia
a differenza dell'Inghilterra le squadre
di calcio della massima serie
percepiscono la parte delle Leghe e
delle Federazioni dei contributi che
sono enormi per le società importanti e
piccolissimi per le società più piccole
per le neopromosse quindi il campionato
per dire di serie A è un campionato
impari per definizione perché già nella
ripartizione dei diritti c'è un sistema
tale per cui le grandi risorse vengono
date ai grandi Club
pur potendo contare su altri introiti e
piccoli Club non hanno i piccoli Club
prendono sostanzialmente le briciole una
cosa che io dico sempre e per farvi
capire come all'interno delle singole
squadre c'è la meritocrazia il più bravo
va avanti ma il sistema del campionato
italiano in questo momento
crea sperequazione attraverso una non
giusta non equilibrata ripartizione
delle risorse pensate che il campionato
di Serie A finanzia il campionato di
Serie B cioè da un aiuto al campionato
di Serie B un aiuto economico e le tre
squadre che sono chiamate
a versare le proprie risorse per aiutare
il campione di serie B sono le tre neo
promosse c'è gli uniche tre che debbono
finanziare il campionato di Serie B sono
le tre più piccole quindi non è un
problema che riguarda le Big ma sono
solo le ultime tre a doversi fare carico
di contribuire
a sostenere il campione di serie B
quindi le piccole sono destinate a
diventare sempre più piccole
perché
è un processo all'incontrario quindi le
piccole per poter far bene non devono
essere solo Brave Ma devono essere
straordinarie Sperando piano piano nel
tempo di diventare sempre un po' meno
piccole e un po' più grandi ma finché
sono piccole con l'ordinario col farbene
far tutto in maniera rigorosa non basta
bisogna essere straordinari Ecco perché
a turno sono destinate sempre a
capitolare e a conservare le grandi
Allora noi ci dobbiamo creare un sistema
meritocratico interno talmente
meritocratico da saper affrontare le
sperequazioni di un macro sistema che è
meritocratico tra club non lo è affatto
è una è un viaggio difficile è un
viaggio spesso impossibile che in questi
anni mi ha arricchito tantissimo A
livello umano non per quello che vi ho
detto Nell'ultima parte non tutti gli
aspetti che riguardano la ripartizione
delle risorse ma per quello che vi ho
detto all'inizio perché oltre a un
pallone che rotola a un palo a una
traversa c'è un gol una squadra di
calcio di un territorio e la massima
espressione per sentirsi cittadino di un
posto
e la massima espressione per sentirsi
connaturato con penetrato nella cultura
di un posto e sia che si viva quella
realtà vivendola sul territorio sia che
si sia altrove sia come vi ho detto si
sia cittadini del mondo e attraverso
l'appartenenza alla scuola di calcio pur
a migliaia di chilometri di distanza
Come accade tutti i giorni si fa un
viaggio attraverso la scuola di calcio
per esserci per pensare in salentino per
pensare al proprio territorio per gioire
insieme di una vittoria con tutti gli
atti tifosi sparsi del mondo e anche
qualche volta di condividere il dolore e
la delusione con prepoteritario Se ci
pensate non ci sono molte altre forme di
aggregazione che su questi grandi
sentimenti della gioia e della
Sofferenza aggregano la gente intorno
alla propria territorialità e alla
propria appartenenza e grazie
[Musica]